what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we apparently got
ourselves a final trailer for The Super
Mario Brothers movie join with me today
John how are you it's me I'm excited I'm
the first person to join us with a
trailer they were just about to shoot a
movie reaction but this dropped and we
haven't moved reaction that just went up
today Jennifer's Body they have Puss in
Boots it's rocks dryer yeah a lot of
people just saying your name there the
only response is it's a me and you stole
it to me but it's also a me it's me a
Roxy yeah there you go see it works guys
follow Roxy on the World Girls YouTube
channel you could also follow her on her
social media it's the only thing that
keeps her coming back in other words
validation ladies and gentlemen leave a
like comment below who your favorite
Mario character is quickly who is it oh
Luigi Peach
Chris Pratt let's go
where am I
oh fresh meat for the grind yes Luigi's
Mansion Vibes he is cute but he is
It's gotta be a way out of here there's
no escape the only hope is the sweet
really fun day
oh you've got to be kidding me
my Army Koopas Goombas whatever those
things are
destroy the Mushroom Kingdom
Bowser is coming I'm not afraid I'll do
anything for my brother we're going to
save him
Epic
the run for it this is fun
I'm so excited for this Mad Max Rainbow
Road sick
sick wow
[Music]
pretty sure I've done that move
yes throw it throw it
the very Mario Kart heavy trailer yeah
suck at throwing those damn green shells
I suck at throwing them third time to
charm just now so yeah you'll get there
one day that really capitalized on the
epicness the I saw like an Avengers
level movie so so bombastic with action
sequences and Mario and Donkey Kong
teaming up I'll throw it to you Roxy
what'd you think I thought that that was
of the trailer so far the most that
looked like I was watching my brother
play the game like it just looks like
the video game in a cool way like it
actually showed that they're going to be
pulling a lot from the game and also I
love Peach and this had the most peach
in it so go Peach it looks like Peach is
going to be whooping ass Peach is woke
right Roxy Peach is dope that's what
matters the most people are gonna walk
away from this going this is an sjw
right Rock
come on because she has no political
opinions at all oh my God why are you
pushing your agendas here in this video
Ryan what did you think
Peach I can't help it we've got big eyes
we look identical to each other I've got
to push my agenda I don't know which one
to shoot
I just setting you up no yeah I thought
this I think that's a really good call
this one feels the most like you're
watching moments ripped out of the games
and you've got your Peach action for me
last trailer they've referenced you know
Luigi Mansion here they're in a big
spooky situation they keep teasing me
with these Luigi's Mansion Vibes and so
I'm just hoping this does well enough to
get that movie greenlit but yeah uh I
love the just sheer scope of like we're
throwing all of Bowser's forces Goombas
Koopas and whatever you spiky Turtles
are called and uh yeah like the
combination of that that like big Epic
War quality but with all the candy
colors and fun of the Mushroom Kingdom
and all that stuff this looks like a
blast and it's funny to me that Chris
Pratt is still like the least featured
vocal character I still hide his voice
quite a bit do you think on purpose
because it's not that good or why yeah I
I'm under the impr I mean I'm still
waiting to find out you know I will wait
to judge because but I do think that
there's a lack of it's just Rings like a
lack of confidence to me because of the
fact that it is
it's Mario it's called the Super Mario
Brothers movie he's smart he's the title
lead character they should be showing a
little bit more of his voice but the
little bits I've heard haven't been
um like upsetting to me in any regard uh
but I think Charlie Day's voices Luigi
is perfect I think he's absolutely
nailing it and what's cool about this is
that there's such a big variation of
Mario games you know you got Super Smash
Brothers you got Mario Kart you got
Paper Mario got Super Mario Odyssey you
got Mario Party Mario Party Luigi's man
and it feels like they have creep
managed to create a movie in a world
right it's just a trailer it should be a
great trailer it does feel like they
managed to create a movie in a world
where all of it's going to be able to
mesh together in a great way with and
even capitalizing on the Mario Kart with
the with the Rainbow Room side of things
feels like a little psychedelic to me
yeah which is something I wasn't
expecting to to say out of this film
um but I'm also excited for like because
they seasoned the trailer and Donkey
Kong and Mario fight and now they're
showing and then teamed up together I
does feel like we are building to some
giant Nintendo Cinematic Universe of
sorts needless to say who do you think
you're going to like most after seeing
the movie uh I feel like I feel I
honestly all jokes aside I feel like
Peach will probably be a scene and Luigi
I feel like it's gonna be Peach and
Luigi thank you so much I have a lot
invested in her thank you as well
because I have a lot of Investments yeah
I'm just going to say I just wanted to
keep you guys happy I'm just gonna say
toad to be a contrarian and I love
Keegan Michael Key he is great they do
get some incredible actors to be the
voices yeah it's weird how like with
that with so much Chris Pratt
controversy like pretty much every other
casting choices like that's a great call
yeah really well done I love the part
because as much as I love the Mario
games I do forget the names of so many
of the creatures and characters from
time to time so when Bowser is listening
off like Koopas Koopas whatever you guys
are like that is so relatable I think
for a lot of audience members because
there are a lot of these reoccurring
creatures that appear in the games and I
have no idea what they're called to this
day even though they appear in like
multiple video games somebody at home is
screaming at the TV right now this is
what they're called leave a comment yeah
I know they're called rollers
usually something pretty simple it's a
blockhead or something of that regarding
except for Jack Black yeah I love Jack
Black and he does have a really unique
voice I've heard actually some people
not stoked about him he's the other
casting that I've heard people not that
excited about oh really I don't feel
that way I'm I'm really into Jack Black
I feel like he's doing a really
everything we're hearing so far it feels
like he's the one who probably has the
perfect tone yeah out of everyone here
and I feel like people going into this
were like I Don't Know Jack Black
because he's liable to just be Jack
Black and and for someone like me that's
appealing but here yeah I'm thrilled
that he seems to be throwing himself
into the role and they seem to have done
uh maybe a little pitch correcting two
so it's a combination yeah him doing the
voice and then them editing it and so
yeah I think he's actually like the
perfect guy and he's a guy who like you
could imagine acting out all the posters
yeah
yeah absolutely and I think that helps
with something like this do you guys
feel like you have an understanding of
what the story is gonna be yeah it's
really simple there's this thing called
the Mushroom Kingdom it's way down here
Bowser is creating all kinds of tyranny
Overlord warlord crap and then Mario
gets plunged into the Mushroom Kingdom
and then he's going to help save the day
by working with the oppressed it's kind
of like Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
plot line but
um you know
[Laughter]
yeah I love it I love it guys what did
you think about this trailer leave your
thoughts down below thank you Roxy for
joining us looking forward to you guys
shooting the Ip Man reaction and
um I'm I'm Christian harloff this is
Brett shirt
oh let's send this to the picture
Garth McMurray we have a patron of the
day shout out to do and then Roxy
recognized your name right away and what
was your response to that I love Garth
he's the best he's amazing so thanks
Garth yeah for sure word Garth what's
your favorite thing about girth yeah
make it personal and real and relatable
I know a lot about Garth actually we've
been with each other for a long time
um serious relief that he's an East
Coast dude that he knows a lot about
comic books that he's always very
generous and supportive uh he's got like
a very challenging life and backstory
and he always tries to stay positive and
helpful to other people he's a good dude
dude Fred said you have for failure and
you are knocked that out of the
cars don't come at me with Garth trivia
well we just learned something about you
Garth well thanks for supporting the
reject Nation buddy see you guys soon
[Music]